[Music]
hardly any other series has caused as
much buzz this year as the south korean
netflix project squid game
for weeks we could hardly save ourselves
from memes discussions and sadly many
spoilers now that the excitement has
died down a bit we have a better
perspective on what happened which is
why in today's original we will not only
explain the end of season 1 but also
share some thoughts on season 2 as well
of course for those who haven't seen the
first season yet spoilers are eminent
let's start with season 1 which is full
of symbols and subtle hints first let's
take a look at the plot and the main
characters of the most successful
netflix series of all time the concept
is quite simple in a total of 6 south
korean children's games
456 adults have to compete against each
other almost all of them are heavily in
debt and aim to take home the gigantic
jackpot of
45.6 billion won which is the equivalent
of 38.6 million us dollars there are
crux of the matter the children's games
which at first seem harmless are
modified in such a way that participants
are disqualified at the slightest
mistake this is a very euphemistic way
of saying that they are either killed by
the game itself as in red light green
light or by one of the numerous
supervisors if they fail a task like in
the game of marbles for example right
from the first game the players realized
that the six tasks will not be a walk in
the park because after the first round
not even half of the participants are
left let's now briefly look at the most
important characters the focus is on
xion jung who makes various
acquaintances with other participants
over the course of the games including
number 067 number 101 and number 001
especially towards the end gion's
friendship with his closest friend joe
sung-woo takes the spotlight and not
only because the two are the last
survivors of the five previous games
now let's get to the important imagery
that runs throughout the whole series
firstly there's the fact that the
participants are obviously not treated
as people but as objects they lose their
entire identity and are consistently
addressed by the mysterious operators of
the game with their participant number
in fact this already begins in the first
episode when the unknown businessman
suggests a round of the game dakshi to
gion giving him money for every round he
wins but also a slap in the face for
each time he loses this is a preliminary
test to determine whether the
participants are even susceptible to
being objectified indeed this series
conceals a lot more than mere social
criticism in the show poor is not
synonymous with good and those who are
rich are not necessarily evil the
boundaries between participants
supervisors and the frontman are vague
which is demonstrated not least by the
fact that police officer juno finds his
strongly missed brother behind the front
man's mask rather than in the morgue the
same goes for the so called vips and the
competitors many of them get into their
desperate situation through gambling
addiction and put their lives on the
line not least because of it but are the
vips so much better aren't they the ones
who bet astronomical sums on the game
players because being mere spectators
doesn't give them enough thrills a
similar symbolism concerns the two
childhood friends gil and sangwoo in the
final game they are the very ones facing
each other the two who at first sight
could not be any more different kion
seems to be the gambling addicted loser
who doesn't take care of his daughter
and still lives with his mother because
he can't afford his own apartment due to
his compulsive gambling zhong wu on the
other hand is the successful businessman
who appears to be the only one who has
made it from the bottom to the top and
is the pride and joy of his family the
longer you observe him the clearer it
becomes that he is not a whip better
than giun in fact the opposite is true
because not only does he flat out lie to
his mother he has also raised his own
gambling addiction to a much higher
level by using his company's funds so
the coin toss that takes place at the
beginning of the sixth game is actually
emblematic of the two friends they both
represent a part of the same coin at the
end when gun suggests that they both
leave the game with no price in exchange
for their lives senwoo opts to end his
life his very existence would be worth
nothing without the price and in any
case he would never have been able to
face his mother again ashamed of his own
ruthlessness after all he had been her
pride and joy
so in the end guillen wins the squid
game and does the entire competition he
is simply dumped on the street of course
not without the gigantic price of 45.6
billion won in a specially set up bank
account as well as the card that goes
with it this series eventually jumps a
year into the future and the viewer is
confronted with the reality that this
severely traumatized gion is living even
worse than he did before he has not used
any of the money in his bank account and
it appears that he would rather have
returned to his old life without money
in exchange for zang wu
thus the money is more or less an
unnecessary burden that he didn't want
in the end for the viewer this is a
rather unsatisfying ending because
although hardly anyone felt much
sympathy for the often completely
exaggerated geon one at least wished
that he would do something with the
money eventually for instance by taking
care of his daughter or the surviving
relatives of his teammates
or at the very least live a somewhat
carefree life
then out of nowhere he gets an
invitation from player 01 the friend he
actually thought was dead whom he
shamelessly deceived at first glance
during the game of marbled
the plot twist that double one is
actually the mastermind behind the games
was definitely not anticipated by many
the actually lovable and terminally ill
old man was too funny and authentic
ultimately it turns out that he
conceived the game purely for the
thrills it would give him and his vips
the only genuine thing about his faked
up story is the brain tumor that has
since confined him to bed he bets that
no one will help the dying homeless man
across the street before he freezes to
death miserably after all his premises
that all people are fundamentally
selfish
number double one dies in the course of
the encounter but more importantly the
homeless man is actually rescued by
strangers as a result guillaume is given
a wake-up call and finally sees some
meaning in his life and that is to end
the cruel games once and for all and be
in control of his own destiny with the
money he has won he ends up being seen
at the airport with a fancy suit and a
new hair color the red hair is probably
the most important symbol especially
with a possible second season in mind
throughout the series the color is green
and red have a superior meaning while
the green suits with the numbers
embroidered on them stand for the
helplessness of the participants their
color red symbolizes power not least
because all the games organizers wear
red suits throughout the show now
guillen himself wears red hair obviously
because he has become powerful however
he does not want to use his power for
cruel games instead he wants to use it
for the good for example for sebiuk's
brother whom he entrusts to the care of
seung-woo's mother along with a large
sum of money at a subway station he
eventually realizes that their games are
still taking place which is why he
henceforth makes it his mission to
avenge all the dead participants and
ruin the games
so much for the end of the first season
much more important though is the
question of what the plot might consist
of if there is to be a second season in
the following we have prepared a few
possibilities we believe could actually
happen in this or a similar way
the first and most obvious theory is
that geo will do everything in his power
to end the games he will either return
his participant to wreck the games more
or less from within or he will somehow
sneak in as a guard similar to what the
police officer did in the first season
he becomes the honorable avenger of all
those who were objective and lost their
lives perhaps in the end there will even
be a face-off between the front man and
kion this theory may seem obvious since
it would tying directly with season 1
yet the entertainment value would not be
nearly as great as it was in the first
season since you would like that new
certain something
another aspect we can think of is that
the story of the two brothers in you and
you know may not be over yet you know
ended up being shot by his brother and
falling off a cliff into the sea in most
movies this doesn't mean anything
especially when someone who's presumed
dead is suddenly out of sight it is
almost a guarantee that the person who
has miraculously survived related to
this could be the telling of the front
man's backstory how did he manage to
survive all of the games and why did he
choose to run them after winning season
2 could thus become a mix of the
frontman story and eventual alliance
between the survivor juno and kyun in
fact we consider this to be one of the
most likely scenarios not only because
series creator huang dong-hyuk has
already confirmed during an interview
with the times that he would be
interested in exploring the frontman
story in a possible second season
it is also not too far-fetched to assume
that season 2 will revolve around the
manipulator el nino his number 001 could
be emblematic of the very first squid
game which the new season could take a
closer look at we would meet the first
vips get a glimpse behind the scenes and
witness how the games are becoming
progressively more professional this
could also mean that we get to see more
violent games than in season 1 as they
have never been tested on real people
before and could therefore be even more
deadly along the way lm's story and
motivation could also be told this is
certainly not the preference of many
viewers but it is still feasible
lastly we would like to share with you
another exciting theory that is somewhat
in line with our first theory guillen
tries to end the games and eventually
becomes the front man himself in fact
this is a very classic ending for a
series like this however
it bugs us that the character
development of guillain would have to
undergo a 180 turn in order to make it
credible still there's no reason not to
assume that this is exactly what
happened with the current frontman in
home maybe he too wanted to put an end
to the entire thing but then decided to
become the frontman himself due to
various reasons the interesting part of
this theory is that there would be room
for many other theories as well so it is
possible that gion and juno team up to
stop the front man but by plot twist
goon ends up killing both the frogmen
and you know when he merges as the
overpowering leader of the games we feel
there are enough theories out there that
are far less plausible
so much for our latest original now we
are interested in your opinion are you
convinced by our theories and if so
which ones do you think are likely
perhaps you even have a hunch yourself
feel free to let us know in the comments
and if you want to see more videos like
this in the future leave us a like and
subscribe to us see you next time
[Music]
you